well we're going to take you live now to
the old bailey where the former
assistant chief constable paul fulwood
is making a statement after the killer
of six-year-old ricky neve in 94 was
jailed for life today
and it's a promise that we've kept
historical murders are notoriously
difficult to investigate
and this came with significant
challenges
but we've used every tool available to
overcome these obstacles
this result was possible thanks to a
committed and hard-working team
closely linked into the crown
prosecution service
and the support from ricky's family
and witnesses involved in the original
case
ricky was a six-year-old little boy
he was a kind and cheeky chap
who was cruelly taken under the most
horrendous of circumstances
his memory lives on
through his family who've had to deal
with his loss for the rest of their
lives
but now they finally know
they have answers
they know what happened
and they know who took ricky from them
and we really really hope this gives him
some peace
for years watson had hidden away
knowing he was responsible for ricky's
murder
and thinking he'd gotten away with it
but this is no longer the case
he will spend years behind bars
and the truth is finally out
thank you
happy to take any questions
and former assistant chief former
assistant chief constable paul forward
you know our investigation has always
been focused on the the murder of ricky
neve we've never ever looked at the
child cruelty offences of course that
was relevant in the first uh trial and
of course in our trial
with this conviction today you know over
the last couple of months but actually
from our perspective our focus has
always been about ricky's murder and
ricky's death and that's where our focus
has been so we you know we can't comment
on that particular point
how would you describe the initial
investigation and ruth as has
the country police at the time
maliciously went after
i mean i think in 1994 how murder was
investigated then is very different from
how we investigate murder now they
didn't have the benefit of dedicated
murder teams disclosure regimes were
very different
the training of officers were very very
different the governance around
investigations is very very different
and forensics was nowhere near where it
is now and i think it's fair to say that
that wouldn't happen now by today's
standards and today's murders i think
from the original investigation and i've
gone on record saying this before and
i'll say it again you know we think that
it was a tunnel vision uh investigation
we think they were very much focused on
one particular line of inquiry which
took them away we can understand how the
way the direction they went but actually
you know by today's standards that just
wouldn't happen we'd like to think that
wouldn't happen did they make mistakes
i
i i think by the the you know the
acquittal of roof me for the the um the
first trial and our conviction of james
watson absolutely you know they charge
the wrong person you know but without
shadow of a doubt today was about
justice for ricky and about making sure
that james watson was convicted for the
dreadful dreadful murder of six-year-old
ricky
owed an apology now so ruth neve i've
actually apologized to roof um i've
apologized to her for the length of time
this investigation has taken to bring
justice for ricky you know and i can
understand in terms of the hurt and the
pain that she's gone through and i've
actually spoken with ruth on a number of
occasions
and given her my own personal apology
with regards to how we've got to where
we are and i wish we'd resolved it much
much quicker do you believe he's ever
shown any remorse he listens to his
conviction i've not seen any remorse
from uh james watson i've seen somebody
who is a fantastic fantasist a
compulsive liar a sexual predator
you know the judge's remarks today in
terms of a sexual interest in young
children you know the way that ricky was
murdered the way it was laid out the
history with previous girlfriends
animals dead et cetera et cetera and
i've not seen any evidence of james
watching shown any remorse for the
dreadful dreadful murder of ricky never
that wasn't the dna database at that
particular
she don't time a problem with your
investigation what she has a problem
with the initial investigation is she
wants an equality called key which of
course as a whole not just you as an
individual will she get that so i i
think it's fair to say and i go back to
i've i've apologized to ruth and eve and
the family for the length of time the
investigation's taken and and mistakes
were made there were lines of inquiry
that we never followed up and quite
clearly the constable at the time went
down a particular road which took us
completely away from the real person
responsible for the murder of ricky neve
and i i think in terms of an apology
i've given my apology to roof all those
officers and all those people involved
in it prior that time they've all
retired they've all moved on they're
nowhere to be linked into the constable
at this moment in time you know that's
something that we'll continue to have
conversations with the needs around but
they've got my personal apology about
what's happened and the dreadful
dreadful experience they've been through
do you think so much of the evidence
so much of the evidence is actually
there to
[Music]
no i don't think so i mean i i i you
know when i reflect back to 1994 and
this is what people need to sort of put
their mindset around this is that this
was shortly after the jamie bulger
murder there was a massive massive focus
on cambridge staff at the time a lot of
pressure and i can understand in terms
of actually why they went down a
particular road i can understand it
however the way that they dealt with
murder in 1994 is very very different
from how we deal with it today they
didn't have the benefit of forensics
they didn't have the benefit of
dedicated homicide murder teams they
didn't have the benefit of governance
around them in terms of experts and
people who would give advice and
guidance as we would have now today so i
i don't probably accept at that
particular time that you know they've
solved it any quicker there were missed
opportunities and there were missed
opportunities and you know there's
lessons that have been learned and those
are lessons that will be learned in
terms of moving forward that we will
know and you know remind other people
involved in homicide investigation going
forward
well we're going to leave that there
that statement from former assistant
chief constable paul fullwood
apologizing to the family of ricky neve
as his killer is sentenced at the old
bailey today for ricky's murder almost
three decades ago james watson has been
sentenced to life in prison with a
minimum of 16 years